ciao a tutti sono valentina rodini
dicono da tokyo due mesi fa dopo che già
tanto più così leggeri femminile insieme
a federica vincendo l'oro
ecco io faccio vantaggio lo facciamo mai
da 17 anni quindi da quando avevo 9 anni
e sono tanta crescita della città di
cremona ho conosciuto questo
[Musica]
passarella minore di un maschio seguito
ragazzo e in particolar modo facevo che
era che insieme a lui doveva mondo
totalmente maschile
quindi quando ho conosciuto due legali
che crescevano canotaggio sembrato mondo
fantastico perché ha fatto di risate
fatto il divertimento di femmine è
spostata nella canottieri bissolati
infortunio animali in questo mondo
rosato e nera fantastico poi negli anni
li ha scoperti che invece non è che dio
del mondo come il mondo il cantante non
è così rosea come immaginavo però non fa
niente io mi sono quello mi è bastato
per farmi innamorare di questo sport ho
iniziato quanti gelido e nico più si fa
vivo in palestra del cantante mi ha
fatto provare il movimento sono una
macchina
movimenti in barca ma dopo 5 minuti mi
fa no no vieni con me invece andiamo ci
diamo in acqua gli autori di una bambina
di 9 anni che ha diritto ha paura di chi
ne sulla passerella per arrivare a
lazzate e mi ha messo in poco lui con la
barca molto che di fianco i
e ii è stato subito amore cioè io mi
sono subito innamorata di passioni
galleggia gerstein sopra l'acqua
e del sentire l'acqua che scorre fatto
di solito non si prediligono i laghi in
pagare il canta giocate l'acqua profili
ama più grossi condomini in pannelli
stampati sul po e forse più divertente
imprevisti le curve i mulinelli kakà
dietro di comunque fanno imparare a cose
diverse riprendo a sensibilità è diversa
ed è da scoprire sempre cose 9 ogni
giorno
secondo me questa la bellezza e la
particolarità un po del pop
niente se non che ci capitino al 2015 o
sapere martiri sta da anni ho visto
passare in tante persone e con tutte
sono sempre rimasti in contatto per
capire che lo sport
uno dei vantaggi e lo spot e si sa unire
le persone file innamorai di qualcosa
per una forma mentis questi portando a
dieci per tutta la vita
è così che nel 2010 sono in tanti in
squadra nazionale che la prima volta nel
2013 ha preso in italia mondiali quattro
di coppia che una medaglia storica
all'epoca e lì si è aperto un mondo
perfetto il mondo di divertimento e di
collaborazione dei team di vive una vita
quasi paradossale di squadra della
squadra nazionale non essere sole essere
pagato in equipaggio e poter fare grandi
cose assieme ecco da lì mi sono mangiata
o politica tutta la mia vita a questo
sport e
nel 2015 16 tenga in guardia di finanza
nelle fiamme gialle che hanno sede a
sabaudia e così mi sono spostata di
società ma l'abilità e che insomma
sentita abbandonata da cremona o dalla
bissolati negli umani quando tardi
perché quando torno a casa ha da sempre
li ad allenarmi sempre gigi che li
accoglie mi allenatrici di massa hd
allenamenti e questi sono stata
magnifica credo che
avevo un luogo protetto e naio dei
potersi sentire al sicuro
aveva una famiglia qui una delle cose
migliori possa succedere a un atleta
avevo un posto sicuro e questo per me è
un po la pista lato
anche se devo dire che le fiamme gialle
sono una grandissima famiglia che è
accolta guardate r b tuttora mi sostiene
e incoraggia
ecco io da sempre nel 2015 sono
incidente squadra olimpica e limpo la
mia visione è cambiata perché ho
incontrato
non è che sì lo facevano tre
divertimenti per il divertimento sta
alla base dello sport
un altro tutta un'ottica più quasi
studiato avevano un obiettivo in mente
logano ben chiaro e lavorare il tempo
bello e molto in spagna uno contro
l'altro grazie vicende per arrivando
obiettivo
questo vivere quasi 360 giorni all'anno
assieme e suonarsi per un obiettivo è
una visione totalmente nuova per
suicida partecipare al 2016
scoprendo però quando i giovani via
disco quindi una compagna con la quale
non devo più parabola forma e la sfida
che ci si poneva davanti
non è un vuoto perché è un'avventura
magnifica avventura ma quagliarella non
è vano porta andavamo studiato nava ming
sting io mi ricordero sempre che di tipo
ii persone che anche se abituate a stare
assieme e due camminavano in sincro e da
lì ho capito ho capito che quando sono
tornata
bisognava bisognava lavorare con
un'ottica diversa
e così il contagio negato mi ha formato
mentalmente nella fattibilità la persona
che sono adesso possiamo dire che più o
meno sono quattro i focus che mi hai
insegnato il primo è proprio con il
primo è lavorare per un obiettivo che
non è l'obiettivo di oggi gli obiettivi
domani obiettivo un obiettivo che si
pone l'hanno fatto hanno quella data
i clienti italiani accade solo una cosa
nei quattro anni in contante che non
possono partecipare tutti solo i
migliori possono partecipare chi riesce
a passati politiche
essere licence a quei campioni non deve
essere solo un andarci a caso ma
guadagnarselo negarcelo quindi lavorare
per un obiettivo a lungo
ogni giorno dà il massimo d'alema liese
stessi per qualcosa che non è oggi che
non è doma anche faccincani quindi
mangiare i doni e che spiegare in
funzione di un obiettivo un obiettivo
chiaro che si può anche el altro non
sono che ponga degli alti e bassi dei
momenti di crisi perché poi li sito sono
gestiti ve quali c'è un intero staff
tecnico e medico un team di squadra che
ti possono aiutare bisognare paura ad
avere i momenti down
perché l'obiettivo è lontano per quello
che tutti se stessi per quell'obiettivo
la non girarsi indietro mai mettersi
sempre in gioco
ecco
un altro focus chi mi ha insegnato il
vantaggio che bisogna dire come della
sconfitta perché lì federica per tre
anni non siamo riusciti a entrare nella
finale mondiale
sempre sbagliate nella parte più
cruciale nella semifinale per quanto
fatto che sia inter in finale ce la si
può giocare ma se non ci si entra i
giochi sono chiusi sono finiti e diciamo
vito a morte dal progettista sportivo e
noi non ce l'abbiamo fatta tutte le
vostre principali che ci andrò ma quello
non è un problema
bisogna fare bisogna sbagliare tentarci
cantarci tutte le volte che se si dice
che quando doveva moderna un uomo
allenatori scandalizzati o
che non sapevano cosa a dir ci trovavamo
tranquilli che devono ancora in noi
perché impedivano quello che noi non
conoscevamo a vedere non necessitavano a
loro nel ci volevano veramente fede
nell'obiettivo che geova posto tra
quattro anni e quindi non era mai in
cammino comune importante dato ha mai
capito se ha sbagliato il lavorare per
farlo meglio e credo siano delle più
grandi
niente punti di forza che abbiamo trim
sele non scoraggiarsi mai non mollare
mai con la testa volevamo comunque
andare avanti
certo non ci faceva piacere dell'unica
divertente ma
l'importante è imparare che cosa è
andato storto ogni portano è diversa non
fa niente con vicino
a volte nei luoghi non lo rifà alla
seconda volta soprattutto sei molto
eclatanti come alcuni che abbiamo fatto
però ci abbiamo sempre creduto
un altro focus e piante calo da oggi
diciamo è
non aver paura degli infortuni
perché un atleta vanessa cerca sempre di
mettere nostri cella divide dove sta il
suo limite e cerca di superarlo ogni
volta sempre più in alto e quando si
porta però il fisico all'estremo ci si
può sposare degli infortuni non sto
muovendo infortuni
accettiamo il possono accade non è un
problema
non è un problema servizi per l'ecologia
mentalità
spesso si dice che
non bisogna che una caduta bisogna
rialzarsi secondo me non bisogna mai
fermarsi
io mi sono rotto la caviglia e due mesi
prima di tokyo la sesta costola una
microfattura ho avuto due volte a
polmonite
non è un problema importante che se
andando un po lavorare sera con i con
tutti gli altri che ci si affidi ai
medici che si ascolti si ascolti lo
staff tecnico e insieme si produca un
nuovo programma non hanno per invitare i
conti quando sanno quanti perché gli
avversari non si fermeranno solo terme
all'esame m
ecco in particolar modo quest'ultima
fatturate stata fatta due mesi prima di
tokyo è stata molto importante perché si
sarebbe salvato in due mesi ma una
microfattura negato un problema la
saldatura della fatto il problema è la
mia perche hamas kansai pesata il nuovo
tempo ethical e il programma al cento
per cento sino al giorno della gara come
state io senza vecchio ma sei riuscita
del 200 per cento lavorare ho mai cinque
anni causa pandemia e poi rifare line
non essere notato che non mi sono fatta
male mesi prima
può essere la mia non essere in grado di
essere me stessa al cento per cento
ma che gli aveva avuto una fortuna ho
avuto una compagnia di barca avuto delle
compagne di scuola o di uno staff di
allenatori e gli dici che ha sempre
temuto non si sono mai posti il problema
cede chicca per prime molti latina non
ha scritto ton e anche forte di prima
gli volevo che
come faccio ma se lo ci credevo di così
tanto mi x tekken avveduto crederci e lo
versato così allora accettati fai tutto
il fattibile con quello che potevo
utilizzare non potevano stare alta
intensità perché non potevamo età i
battiti per non dilatare la cassa
toracica e poi c'è cosa bassa intensità
di resistenza di pin statico isometrico
non ero pure è importante continuare a
fare tutto quello che potevo sai perché
l'obiettivo è la line mercati finance ed
è fermata solo perché io
e
giovani siamo usciti in acqua fino a
vevo ricordo creato occhio da dieci
giorni di francesco inter legali ancora
vanno questo problema che mi faceva male
la fede con uscita che facevamo
pettinava di amici sono gratis pesava
rientriamo lei non ha mai dubitato di me
anzi cercavo di proteggermi
perché mai avevano diventata una cosa
sola e credo che
ricevere fiducia dai propri compagni
vacane proprio gli attori siano delle
cose più belle con abilità possa
sperimentare nella propria vita
e lo rimane visione che le di averli
porta sempre in dubbio sempre con sé de
vita
abbiamo imparato lee young che
quando entriamo in gara da dopo il
periodo della gara
siamo solo noi e speriamo tutto il mondo
andiamo nella nostra bolla focalizzarci
località ma solo sulla nostra palata
quella palate che abbiamo studiato per
cinque anni quel movimento ben sappiamo
che essere elastico forte che ci
permette di raggiungere la maggiore
velocità
e solo a quello che siamo al nostro
collari sull'acqua essere una cosa sola
s assieme essere decise a monigo insinuo
e fa scorrere la barca sentire quella
sensazione quasi come regolarsi e tutto
il mondo fuori non ci importa campioni
del mondo non ci può capire il mondo
siamo solo dei due camminiamo veramente
a single
abbiamo imparato che punto i maggiori
nostro punto di maggior forza siamo noi
perché le altre cose non le possiamo
controllare ma noi ci siamo applicate
per cinque anni per fare esattamente
quello quindi non solo andare là e
divertirci e fai del nostro mondo
federica me c'è sempre predicendo in
vacca importante tornei due senza agli
impianti aver dato tutto averle tentate
tutti e divertirsi mentre lo si fa
perché lo sappiamo che lo sport e in
fondo si passò divertimento nessuno ci
obbliga a farlo nessuno ci costringe lo
facciamo perché ci dà qualcosa che a
palemo possibile perché non sono
ascrivibili a favore e quindi
questo focus questa bolla questo
silenzio che ci circonda
viene poi esploso con tagliamo colline
del the wild e solo lì allora le
casalinghe interiora bonaccia così è
stata proprio perché è stato per ogni
gag ha vinto pensa che sia eravamo noi
eravamo al cento per cento magari
sbagliavamo magari facevamo bene megawat
monoi noi e il mondo fuori
che decisi a tutto questo l'unico